bonjour claude blanchou maison merci de
répondre à nos questions la dernière
grande ville du pays jalalabad est
tombée ce matin aux mains du talent des
talibans c'est la capitale kaboul reste
pour le moment aux mains du gouvernement
mais jusqu'à quand parce que selon la fp
qui cite à l'instant des habitants de
kaboul des combattants viennent d'entrer
dans la capitale ça vient de tomber
kaboul peut tomber entre les mains des
talibans dès aujourd'hui
dès aujourd'hui je ne vois pas en effet
on a assisté à une campagne
surprise en trois mois les talibans se
sont assuré le contrôle d'abord des
campagnes puis de la moitié des
capitales des provinces et puis de
toutes les grandes villes et ce matin on
apprend comme vous l'avez dit la chute
de djalal abad qui au sud-est de kaboul
est la dernière ville à tomber dans
kaboul et maintenant encerclé en tout
cas les grandes villes qui sont entre 50
et 100 km de kaboul sont aux mains des
talibans l'élément le plus inquiétant
d'ailleurs c'est que beaucoup de ces
villes sont tombées sans combat c'est à
dire que avec le motif ou le prétexte
d'éviter une guerre civile et d'éviter
les morts civiles d'éviter un carnage et
bien les autorités officielles de
l'afghanistan en plein financier ville
se sont rendues aux talibans se sont
rendus hier à part les lions
remonétisation achraf gagné hier à
parler le président du du gouvernement
afghan à a parlé d'une remobilisation
des troupes 1 hier avec ces combattants
qui rentre dans kaboul aujourd'hui se
dire quoi qu'il va y avoir un carnage
justement en effet monsieur monsieur le
président après 10 a parlé d'une
mobilisation des troupes mais dans le
même temps il dit qu'il ya des
discussions politiques avec tout un tas
de dirigeants à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur de l'afghanistan pour
trouver une solution politique
c'est-à-dire que d'une d'un côté
mobilisé ses troupes qui dans le fond
d'eux ne sont pas mobilisables parce que
il ya des bataillons fantôme parce que
il ya beaucoup de corruption il a changé
tout l'état major il ya peu de temps par
à tour des raisons d'inefficacité des
généraux qui dirigent l armée
précédemment et donc cette d'armé et
démoralisés par le départ des soutiens
américains et occidentaux donc
lorsqu'elle est encerclée par les par
les talibans est bien dans beaucoup de
cas dans beaucoup de l'exemple de ville
elle s'est rendue et les taliban ont
promis d'ailleurs la vie sauve au soldat
aux militaires qui se rendaient ici des
certificats comme quoi et se sont rendus
et que par conséquent il n'ya pas
exercer des représailles à leur égard
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer pour
pour la capitale pour kaboul kaboul ça
va durer probablement quelques jours
même quelques semaines pour la raison
très simple c'est que les américains
envoient non plus 3000 et 5000
militaires pour assurer l'évacuation de
leurs ressortissants pour assurer
l'évacuation aussi des
ddd des locaux qui ont travaillé avec
l'armée américaine il y en a beaucoup il
va encore quinze mille personnes
susceptibles d'être inquiétées par les
talibans les américains probablement
n'arriveront jamais à y tuer ses 15000
personnes qui d'ailleurs n'ont pas tous
de visas plus également la même chose
pour les ambassades de divers pays
occidentaux qui ont participé à cette
alliance donc il est probable que kaboul
va tenir simplement en effet les
talibans pour éviter le carnage vont
avoir une stratégie de sièges ils vont
peut-être progressivement
coupé l'eau peut-être l'électricité
coupée les moyens d'approvisionnement
jusqu'à ce que
monsieur rani organise sa reddition sa
reddition plus exactement son
exfiltration probablement vers
l'extérieur donc ça va probablement
prendre quelques jours ou quelques
semaines sauf hypothèse
funeste si les taliban décidé d'entrer
avec des moyens militaires par la force
ce temps kaboul il y aurait probablement
un carnage d'autant plus que le
l'afghanistan est un pays jeune la
moitié de la population a moins de 20
ans moins de 20 ans ça veut dire qu'ils
n'ont pas connu le régime taliban de 96
à 2001 et qu'il n'accepterait pas comme
cela un régime qui empêche jeunes filles
d'aller à l'école à l'université qui
leur demande de rester chez elle et qui
instaure la charia alors que à kaboul on
avait une vie relativement libre depuis
une vingtaine d'années en tous les cas
une information qui vient de tomber que
loin des maisons à l'instant un porte
parole des taliban les talibans l'ordre
de rester aux portes de kaboul et de ne
pas entrer dans la ville même si donc
des habitants ont dit que certains pour
moi tant sont entrés pour l'instant
c'est assez fou c'est ce que l'on sait
pour le moment du côté de kaboul mais
avec cette inexorable percée des
talibans quelles conséquences pour la
région risque d'embrasement dans les
pays alentour bien ou au contraire
risque d'isolement de l'afghanistan on
sait que la russie par exemple à
renforcer les frontières au nord de
l'afghanistan avec les armes aux
méthodes gicquel pakistan qui accélère
la clôture au long de sa frontière avec
quelques années avec l'afghanistan
donc votre confirmation que confirme ce
que des tirs sur la stratégie du siège
adoptée par les par les talibans ça va
prendre du temps pour ce qui est des
pays voisins ils sont tous évidemment
très inquiet d'une part parce que il va
y avoir un exode et ceci à commencer par
l'exode intérieure au fur et à mesure
que les villes tombées il ya eu des
réfugiés qui sont à kaboul qui sont
maintenant dans les jardins publics dans
les lieux publics à kaboul effectivement
que vont devenir ces gens là seule voie
d'évacuation c'est l'aéroport de kaboul
qui est maintenant sécurisée par les
troupes américaines n par 5000 soldats
américains qui sont là d'ici quelques
heures alors du côté des pays voisins on
est inquiet de toutes parts
du côté du tadjikistan et ouzbékistan
qui ont une frontière commune frontières
poreuses d'ailleurs et on l'a constaté
avec le trafic de la drogue puisque
l'aghanistan est en réalité un narco
état qui vit depuis toujours des revenus
du pavot de la drogue et de ce trafic
que malheureusement on n'a pas
véritablement chercher sérieusement
éradiquer pendant les 20 dernières
années cette frontière évidemment doit
être sécurisé et je crois que la russie
en lien avec ses alliés tadjik un ouzbek
est en train actuellement de sécuriser
cette frontière du côté iranien on
craint aussi la contagion idéologique
même si les talibans ont promis de ne
pas envoyer des métastases dans les pays
voisins on craint la confusion
idéologique parce que après tout en iran
les femmes devront à l'université des
femmes dans des postes très importants
dans l'économie ou dans la politique et
ce qui n'a rien à voir avec ce régime
obscurantiste que veulent mettre en
place les talibans même chose côté
chinois puisque une partie du territoire
afghan vient à l'intérieur du sind yang
du pays des ouigours avec lesquelles les
chinois ou quelques quelques problèmes
et les chinois ne veulent surtout pas
que ce mauvais exemple le taliban fasse
tache d'huile chez les rivaux et puis
évidemment la situation déjà actuelle
est plus mauvaise que celle de la
période pendant laquelle les taliban
étaient au pouvoir
2,96 à 2001 puisque à l'époque il ne
contrôlait pas le nord de l'afghanistan
c'était contrôlé par l'alliance du nord
du fameux commandant massoud le
commandant massoud qui d'ailleurs a été
assassiné par des talibans deux jours
avant l'attentât du 11 septembre 2001
coordination parfaite aujourd'hui dans
le jeu dimanche il y à un appel du fils
du commandant massoud qui demande la
france à la france de venir aider à
l'alliance du nord enfin aux cieux ce
qu'il en reste à sécuriser la vallée du
panjshir qui en effet historiquement n'a
jamais été contrôlée par les talibans ni
même par les pays qui ont occupé ce pays
auparavant donc la situation est
extrêmement sérieuse et il est probable
que dans les heures qui suivent il va y
avoir des appels à l'aide humanitaire
pour kaboul des appels à la sécurisation
de la population de ta bouche de kaboul
et les appelle aussi à la solidarité
internationale pour que les différents
états puissent accueillir des réfugiés
merci claude denjean présent pour cette
analyse précise de la situation en
afghanistan sera plutôt vous êtes expert
en relations internationales je rappelle
les deux informations donc qui viennent
de tomber des combattants talibans sont
entrés dans la capitale kaboul selon des
habitants mais les talibans ont l'ordre
de rester aux portes de kaboul et ne pas
entrer dans la ville donc l'information
paradoxal ça c'est une information d'un
porte parole